we're asked to convert the following
equation from point slope to slope
intercept form and so this is the
equation right over here let me get my
little scratch pad out here let me see
if i can remember this it's y plus 13 is
equal to 4 times x plus 2.
so let's write that down we have y
plus 13 is equal to 4
times x
plus 2. so this is in point slope form
and just inspecting this i can tell you
that the slope
of the line described by this equation
is 4. i could tell you that the point
x equals negative 2 y equals negative 13
is on this line so we know the point x
equals negative 2 y equals negative 13
is on this line because when you put
something in point slope form it's of
the form where this is the slope and
this would be x minus one of the points
so x minus negative 2 is positive 2 and
y minus the other correspond the y
coordinate of that point so y minus
negative 13 is positive 13. but let's
actually convert this into slope
intercept form and that of course is a
form
y is equal to mx
plus b where m is the slope and b is the
y-intercept and we're going to do this
just with some algebraic manipulation
and you can imagine once we do this the
m should still be this 4.
so let's do that so the first thing i'm
going to do is distribute this 4 over
the x plus 2. so this is going to be
equal to 4x
plus 4 times 2 is 8. 4 times x plus 4
times 2 so it's 4x plus 8 and we still
of course have our y plus 13 here
and now
we're pretty close to getting into slope
intercept form we just have to subtract
13 from both sides and i'm going to have
it of the form y is equal to something
times x plus something so let's do that
let's subtract 13 from both sides
and we will get on the left hand side
just y and on the right hand side we are
going to have 4 x and then 8 minus 13
is negative 5. so we get y equals 4x
minus 5. and let's just type that in and
see if we got the right result so y is
equal to 4x minus 5. so y is equal to 4
times x
and they just have a positive here so i
would write plus negative 5. the same
thing as 4x minus 5. so let's check our
answer and we got it right